- On this episode, Lewis
stops by to talk greatness.
(hip-hop music)
You ask questions and I answer them.
This is
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 157
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
A.K.A, if you've got a book
come on and hawk that shit on the show.
First my father-in-law,
now my good buddy, Lewis.
Lewis, for the very few
in the Vayner Nation
that don't crossover and
know who you already are,
why don't you give a
little bit of your spiel.
And then India and whatever
will get into the show.
- Okay, a little bit about me?
- Yes.
- About me, I met this guy,
how many years ago did I meet
you, maybe seven years ago?
- Was it the during the Crush It! tour?
- 2009, 2008?
- [Both] 2009.
- This guy inspired me to build a business
and take it to a whole 'nother level.
I was in a transition.
I was sleeping on my sister's couch.
I had a cast on, I broke my wrist
playing professional football.
And the amount of hustle that this guy had
really inspired me to
figure out what I wanted
to do next with my life.
So I spent a lot of time
researching, finding mentors,
studying, taking a lot of
action, making a ton of mistakes.
But learning along the way
in the process of taking
that action and built a
couple seven-figure businesses
along the way and then started a podcast
and that's where the book is coming from.
- The podcast seems to be the place
where your brand took a
different level, right?
Like for me, from afar,
- [Lewis] Next level.
- [Gary] you know, you
were playing the space
and a lot of people try
to build personal brands
and things of that nature
and how does one differentiate?
When did you get serious
about the podcast?
Why did you get serious about the podcast?
- It's interesting because you mentioned
something to me in the car
in St. Louis, Missouri,
when I drove you from an
event to another event
or something in a hotel,
- [Gary] I remember.
- [Lewis] and you said, "I
see you making a lot of money
"and building an audience, but you're not
"at the mainstream level yet."
You said something like, "You're
not at the mainstream media
"level yet, and that's
where I wanna see you go."
So you said this to me and I
remember taking it to heart
because I was making a lot
of money, I was growing.
But I was like, "Do people in the press
"wanna have me on their show?"
- Yup.
- And I said I gotta build--
- You've made the main-stream!
- (laughs) Right, exactly.
And so I spent a lot of
time really figuring out
what does that mean to build a brand,
what does that mean to create
different type of content?
The podcasting world in 2012, late 2012
when I was seeing other
friends getting into it,
I realized this is
something that I could--
- This is happening.
- This is happening,
and I was like I think I can do this.
If these guys can do it, I could do it.
- Yup.
- I didn't know what to expect.
I just said for the first year
I'm not gonna try to make any money.
I'm not gonna take any sponsors.
I'm just gonna go--
- And interview people, put out content.
- And interview the
best people I could find
and give them my all.
- And so it's interesting, in March,
I come out with The #AskGaryVee book.
That's the play of your
podcast into the book.
What are you promising people
that have listened to
your podcast, in this book
that doesn't translate from the--
- Here's the thing, I interview
all these inspiring people,
you've been on the show
and it's like we get
these great lessons, we hear
these stories and that's great.
But what are the actionable
exercises and practices
that we can use in our daily life
to take that action and get the results.
It's one thing to be inspired--
- Did you write this?
Did you do it the way I do
where you have a ghostwriter
and you audio it?
- I work with a couple
people who have helped me
but it's a lot of
interviewing back and forth,
a lot of editing back and forth.
- Yup, can you write?
- A little bit.
As a dyslexic guy, it's kinda challenging.
You know, it's a hard work for me.
- I can't write, right
India and Steve? (laughs)
- That's why one of the principles--
- Have you ever gotten an email from me?
(laughs)
- One of the principles is
building a championship team.
And I know that in order
to put out a great product
I need to have a great team around me
of writers, editors, publisher,
to support the process.
Because I couldn't do it on my own.
- Very cool man.
- [Lewis] There's no way.
- [Gary] Good for you,
congrats, I'm proud of you.
When's it out?
- It's out today.
- Alright, well then let's
link that up, it's a big day.
I'm humbled that you want to be
on this show on your big day.
What else are you doing today media-wise?
- I did Fox and Friends this morning,
or I did Good Day New
York this morning, Fox 5,
I'm doing Fox and Friends this weekend.
But this is the most important
show of the whole week.
- On that note India, let's get into this
- [Both] show.
- [Gary] I like when we get that thing.
What is that called, again?
- [DRock] Harmony.
- [India] I don't know.
- [Gary] What's that?
- [DRock] Harmony.
- [India] It's not.
- [Gary] Harmony.
- [India] I don't think that's what it is.
- It's Harmony, we're harmonizing.
Alright, let's go India.
- [Voiceover] Martina asks, "When making
"important decisions do
you trust your own gut
"and experience or do you
count on some advisor as well?"
- Who's your go-to person
on a real decision?
Do you have one?
- You know, it used to be my Dad,
but he had a pretty extreme car
accident about 10 years ago,
so he can't really
comprehend certain things
at that level anymore.
But I go to a guy named Stewart Jenkins.
Who works at a big brand called Deckers,
a billion dollar shoe company
that owns Ugg and Timba,
and some of those brands.
And he's just like a straight
shooter, tells me how it is,
great family guy.
- Doesn't try to pander to what
you want to hear?
- [Lewis] He doesn't deal with my ego
he just tells me.
He's got such good integrity and morals.
- That's why I don't speak to anybody,
I don't want anybody touching my ego.
- (laughs) Exactly.
So I talk to him with real
issues that speak to the heart.
- What percentage of decisions
do you make on your gut?
- A lot.
- Like what percentage?
- Probably 100%.
- OK, so you really don't
give a shit what Stewart says.
- No, I advise with
everyone on tough decisions
but I always know the answer.
- Got it.
- You know what I mean,
it's like I know the answer,
but I feel like I have to make sure.
- [Gary] Has anybody
wavered you from the answer?
- People have given me different opinions
but I always know, yes, they have.
They have, they waver
me, and then I realize
I shouldn't have taken that advice.
- So at times, where you
haven't gone with your gut
and you've gone with people
that you think have made it
or other things, it hasn't paid off,
so you're now defaulting
as you're maturing
into your own place.
- [Lewis] Yes.
- [Gary] I mean for me,
I've always been that way.
And I think that what happened,
it's interesting to hear
your perspective, it's fun
to have guests a little bit
because you would've gotten my answer of
you know, no!
I respect my Mom and Dad
and things of that nature,
but I don't even,
I love them with all of my heart,
I just make my own decisions.
I don't know what else to say about this.
But it's interesting that--
- I come from an athlete background,
so I was constantly coached,
constantly getting feedback.
So I like to have the coaching,
- That makes sense.
- in an environment so
I can just take action
and apply the information.
But a lot of the times, I know the answer,
it's just trusting
myself a hundred percent.
- That makes a lot of sense.
I think the one thing that is
an actual item of this show
taking the theme from your book
and we'll continue to act on it.
I think you should really try,
if you're watching the show,
to try the opposite on the
next decent sized decision.
As long as it's not a top
three decision in your life,
then do you.
If it's a fourth biggest
decision type of thing,
try the other way as context.
I may even try this, no I can't.
But (laughs)
that didn't even last a sentence.
But, I think that would be interesting.
Because I'm intrigued by
you ending up in this place.
My intuition is a lot of
people end up in that place
as they get older and older,
because at some level,
you'd rather, for me, I'd
rather go down my way.
That to me is probably the thing.
When you're making real decisions
there's upside and there's downside.
That's why they're big decisions.
If I'm gonna go down,
I wanna go down because I screwed up.
Not because somebody else gave me advice
and it just didn't work out.
That's just, yeah, alright India.
- I think that segues really
well into the next question.
- [Gary] Oh, a lot of segueing going on.
- [Voiceover] Gabriel asks,
"What is the best example
"in your life, where your ego
has gotten the best of you?
"How significant was it in retrospect?"
- Well, this is great, right,
because you've already dropped ego.
I almost called this The Ego Show.
So you know, what was the question?
- When the ego got the best of you?
- [India] And how significant
was it in retrospect?
- Oh my gosh, should I go?
- Sure. Yeah go ahead.
- For me, oh man.
Any relationship that I've been in
I allow my ego to get the
best of me in the past.
Where it's like--
- With, like, girls you mean?
- Yes, yes.
- [Gary] Okay, go ahead.
- [Lewis] And then it just
affects me, it like consumes
every decision.
- [Gary] What's the ego part?
Like you think you're hotter than them?
- No, no, it's like after we break up
or end things, it's like--
- You don't wanna call first?
And say, "That was a cool run"?
- I don't know it's just like
I'm still holding onto things
and I can't let certain
things go, and I'm mad still
or pissed, or why it didn't work out.
And that, holding onto things
as opposed to fully letting go,
- Yeah.
- will hold me back in
other areas of my life,
and just my health, my business.
Like making clear decisions.
And that ego, I gotta fully
let go in those situations.
- Interesting.
- What about you?
- For me, I think with ego,
I think it's things that I don't know.
- I thought you know everything.
- Well, I know everything
that actually has happened.
So, maybe my ego of recognizing,
well no, hear me out India.
Like, let me give you an example.
I know you're laughing over
there and having a good time.
Let me explain.
I would tell you that I
slash, it was the right business
decision, but ego of not
doing a lot of television
shows because I feel like
the world's gonna change
and I'll wanna own the IP,
maybe kept me away from being
50 thousand times bigger
because clearly I'd be incredible.
I'd probably be the biggest TV star in TV
if I decided to do a TV show.
- [Lewis] Why haven't you
still done a show?
- [Gary] Because I still believe
in this thesis which is--
- Why can't you do both?
- You can, you can!
- What are you waiting for?
- You know I'm busy as shit here,
what do you think is going on?
I'm busy!
- I'm overwhelmed just being in here.
- You're on one of the
three floors of four offices
like there's a lot going on.
So I wonder if ego has kept
me away from mainstream media.
- But, you were just on
Bloomberg this morning, right?
- Yeah, that's different
than hosting a show.
- You'd be the biggest TV
personality in the world.
- I believe that Lewis, say it again.
India, you say it too.
- You would be the biggest TV personality
in the world.
- [India] You want me to say?
- Yeah, I want you to say it
because I know you don't want to say it.
No, I want you to say it.
- You'd be so huge on television.
- [Gary] No, see what she did, she hedged.
- Nobody would ever be able
to be on TV after you again.
- That was good.
Cut that clip for me,
DRock, just a ringtone.
I think there's been an
enormous amount of things
that have impacted me, predicated my ego.
I just don't know what they are
because they're the
things that I didn't do,
versus the things that I did.
The things that I've done with
my ego, I know the outcomes.
They've all been pretty damn positive.
It's the things that I'm passing on,
that I can never play out and
know what would have happened.
That's where my upside is on the table.
Me being bigger, financially, brand,
happiness, opportunity, me
being bigger is predicated
on my no's, not my yes's.
- What would be the ultimate
show that you could have
on any network, any time?
Who would you be doing it with?
Would it be yourself? What topic?
- You know what's funny, I've
thought about that a lot.
And I don't think about it a lot.
Meaning, I used to think about the format,
what would I want to do.
I'm so not in the mindset of
having a TV show right now.
I'm so enjoying this.
I'm enjoying the way I'm
going about marketing this
and the white spaces and
where the world's going
and how over the top
is changing the world.
Look, if I had a business show on Netflix,
if Netflix came to me right now
and said we want to make you
our business show, that would
be really tough to say no to.
So I would say that,
because it's of the moment.
- Really, not mainstream cable or network,
or anything like that?
- No, because I'd rather
go to where the pucks going
and I'd rather be part
of the narrative of,
you know those shows, House of Cards,
Orange is the New Black,
whatever sports deal they do,
and then that business show.
That's where they competed
with CNBC, ya know?
- That's what I did with the
podcast, I saw the opportunity.
- Yeah, that's exactly right.
And that's where the upside is,
you wait and you let the puck come to you.
I would say CNBC and Bloomberg
are interesting to me
because it's just right
down the pipe of business.
Yeah, I just can't get there.
India?
- This one, we're both
wearing all black today.
- Yeah let's stand up and show everybody.
I'm like really all black.
- Yeah you really are.
- Are you? You're all black.
- Well, I have gray tights on.
- Yeah well I'm, look
at this, black socks.
Look at this, black underwear.
- Wow.
- Yeah, I'm all black today.
- It's just really dark today.
- Super dark.
- [Lewis] We'll be matchy-matchy.
- Yeah, get in there.
Alright.
- B?
- B!
- [Voiceover] B asks, "How do
you deal with losing a client?
"Just lost one and I'm mad as hell."
- Yeah, mad as hell is good.
I think mad as hell is appropriate.
When I lose a client, the
first thing that I think about
is what did I do wrong?
And then, most of the
time I have an answer.
If I don't have an answer,
I try to figure it out.
But, I'm pretty interesting
when it comes to losing a client.
I'm very much onto the next one.
I on the other hand am very lucky.
Listening to you is really interesting.
I was sitting here and saying my god,
my ability to dump and
move on in any situation,
relationships, business,
it's the game for me.
It's why I'm always in a good mood.
I literally sit on bad news and bad stuff
for fractions of seconds.
DRock's shaking his head, right?
- What about with intimate
or personal relationships,
with friends or family?
Now do you just say screw you,
I'm off to the next person?
- I haven't really lost
anybody who I would call
in my most inner circle.
I've had relationships
that have, like, my longest
girlfriend relationships
that ended were predicated
on me sitting on it longer than,
it was in my head for a long time anyway.
So, yeah, I mean, I don't know.
I've been very blessed that
somebody that meant the world
to me hasn't decided to leave me.
So that's one part of it.
And, the other part is,
I haven't, outside of a couple long-term
girlfriend relationships, I
haven't parted from anything
that's been in my inner core.
In business, I've had to fire
people I care a lot about.
But, I've come to a
place where I recognize
that I was doing more
harm by keeping them here
and giving them no growth
here, Wine Library.
So, yeah, that's that.
Anything that you want to add on that?
- No.
- Alright. Let's do it.
- This is from Jarek.
- Oh, Jarek.
I've been seeing Jarek
- [Lewis] Is it Robbins?
- [Gary] show up a bunch.
Hamilton, he's been popping
up a bunch lately on my feed.
- Hey what's going on Gary Vee?
My company got accepted to be
a part of the Alpha Program
at Collision 2016 in New Orleans.
I've never been to an event like this,
so I'm not really sure
what to prepare for,
how to prepare for it.
I was wondering, what would
you do if you were in my shoes,
if you were going to not
necessarily look for money,
but more looking to make contacts?
I'd appreciate any information,
any insights you might
have on the situation.
Thanks, Gary.
- [Gary] That's real nice.
Jarek, really legit American
flag waving so beautifully
in the background.
I did notice the Giants t-shirt,
so I'm a little bit pissed with Jarek now.
Lewis any thoughts on that?
I think you wanted to establish your name
in the marketing and business world.
I assume you started
going to a lot of events
for the first time through
the last half decade?
How did you approach it?
- I remember when I was
broke, on my sister's couch,
I took a Greyhound to one
of my first events in 2008.
It was in New York.
It was like a sports
film festival in Philly.
I took a Greyhound,
and I had a suit jacket
and a carry-on case.
I remember I had a hostel
room that I got for like $17.
Because I knew the value.
I met a guy named Ben
Sterner, who I think you know
who works out of here.
He was like, "You've got
to come to this event.
"You're gonna meet a
lot of powerful people
"that's gonna help your business,
"your relationships, your brand."
So I was like I gotta get there.
I rented a hostel for $17 the first night.
I walk in, late at night
and there's throw-up all over the ground.
There's throw-up all over the
floor, all over the bathroom,
and 20 snoring, European guys in the room.
But I knew the value right
when I got to this event
how important it was to connect with
influencers and powerful individuals.
And I stayed up all night with people
and just built a relationship with them.
It wasn't about being at the event
it was figuring out where people
were going after the event.
And getting in with their friends
and then creating friendships with people.
I never talked about
business or asked for advice.
I just said, "What's
going on in your life?"
Like how can we be buddy-buddy?
And, let's do thumb-wrestling
wars, whatever,
like I did with you in 2009 or something.
It's like let's have fun
as opposed to talking about
the thing you don't want
to talk about right now.
- You know to me, Jarek, I think
it's a really good question
and I think that's right.
I think at some level, if
you're not meeting people,
you're not hitting on your KPI.
I think Lewis speaks to
patience in a relationship,
I think it really matters.
Trying to throw around your business card
or pitch your business, is
completely the opposite move.
- Not to cut you off,
but to set an example,
I've been essentially jabbing
for six years with you.
- That's right.
- I never asked for anything.
- I bought a shit-load of these books.
- But I've never asked for anything
except for
- [Gary] This book.
- [Lewis] The blurb on the back.
Which you know.
- Which is a big deal
because I don't like giving them out.
- And also hey, can I come on the show.
And, you bought some books, yes.
- Which is my own advice, right?
I talk about that a lot which
is cash in all those chips
when you've got your signature moment.
Like you need this to do well.
It's another watershed
moment in your career.
- Before, what was that guy's name again?
- Jarek.
- For Jarek, I would not
ask anyone for support
or help right now.
I would just say how can I give
that person a relationship.
- Listening to Lewis' narrative, Jarek,
I think one of the
biggest things that people
make mistakes for, is
they go for short-term
nickels and dimes instead
of long-term dollars.
So, if you find, the more
important the person you encounter
in New Orleans, the more you
should not ask for anything.
Too many times, the amount
of people that roll up on me,
I have no idea who they are,
and they want $100,000 from me
because they're gonna
help me buy the Jets.
It's pretty intense, there's no context.
It's not the right move.
Again, back to his story.
Go sleep with 20 snoring
throw-up dudes for $17
if you've got a practical
financial problem.
Have the humility to go
sleep on your sister's couch,
if you have a financial problem.
If your financial problem
needs to be solved
by you going to the most important people
on first impact and asking for $25,000,
you've put yourself in a bad position.
So I think what you need to do
is put yourself in a position
where you put no pressure on yourself
to close at this event,
but build at this event.
- And look at the long-term.
Think of relationships for
five years down the line.
- Hundred percent, India?
- Last one from Adam.
Will privacy related, sorry--
- Am I freaking you out?
- No, I'm kinda used to it.
Will privacy related--
- Well you said privacy like (laughs)
- [Voiceover] Adam asks,
"Will privacy related issues
"be the ultimate Achilles
heel for Social Networks
"including Facebook?"
- I'll jump in here.
The answer is no, because
there's a pendulum swing.
The reason Snapchat
grew was because it was
a safer place, a place
that stuff would disappear.
I actually think the
next wave is gonna be,
I think they'll be more
closed over the next decade.
You've got Cyber Dust, Cube's thing,
you've got Snapchat.
I think there's more room for that.
I think there will be another one or two.
I think the reason WhatsApp and
other things of that nature,
messaging apps are doing
well is in theory to people,
it's closed by comparison.
But I think actually
in the long long-term,
10, 12, you know 8, 10, 12 years from now
there will be another push back to open.
It's generational, right?
It's like fashion.
It goes through ebbs and flows.
As a matter of fact, with
everybody being so kind of hipster
and the way everybody is now,
the other day I was thinking,
"Crap, I wonder where
"like when are we gonna
go conservative again?"
Like when everybody got
the Friends haircut.
I'm curious and I was
thinking about grunge,
which was crazy weird.
Anyway, it made me think about that
and that's how I think
about Social Networks.
This is the mood of a generation.
The 60's were different
than the 70s and the 80s
and 90s and 2000s.
I definitely think people
will freak out about privacy.
I think Ashley Madison is
a proxy to other things.
Just imagine now all of us,
if all of our information
of every text, email and
engagement, and I mean texts
and WhatsApps and whatever
else you're using to creep.
Tinder.
Imagine all those conversations plop out
and they're just searchable.
Literally Lewis, everything
you've said digitally.
Yeah, and so I actually
think that happens.
And then I think Nirvana happens
because everybody realizes
how flawed everybody is.
So, I've got a very weird,
positive point of view
in where this all goes.
I think there'll be
some, I do think privacy
will contain people to
some different behaviors.
But I actually think if you
play the chess moves out,
everybody's laundry gets aired out,
which changes society forever.
And we roll in a completely different way
and the things we accept as
norms, the way we think about
interpersonal relationships
and what makes a good person
and what makes a good
person and a bad person,
fundamentally changes with
the great data breach of 2022.
- Because everyone, we realize
that everyone's a freak.
- Well, I mean (laughs) you
take it where you want, Lewis.
But I definitely think that
that's a real possibility.
I think that--
- When do you think that will happen by?
- I don't know.
- I like your predictions.
- I don't like to predict
things that I don't,
I like to predict things
that already happened
that everybody didn't
realize they happened.
This way I'm right.
I think that, I just think
it's a real possibility
and I definitely live my
life with all my flaws
and what have you with the
knowledge of that could happen,
and we have to be prepared
for the repercussions of,
like I always say the right
thing is always the right thing.
Like the end score is the end score.
If you do wrong things
by today's standards
and they become aware, you'll
have to deal with that.
- So do you like that you
put yourself out there
in such an authentic
way, a vulnerable way,
a lot of times where you
talk about your flaws
because then, if it does come out
people are like, it doesn't matter.
- But I'm a human being,
I think a lot about
when I'm doing things in
a very private setting,
how that maps to my public persona.
Like if this hits the fan,
does that undermine what I'm
saying and I try to stay in
that lane because it will still
at least make sense in my narrative.
You can't be the person that says like
that holier-than-thou guy
that was cheating on his wife.
You can't be like the prosecutor
and go after prostitution
when you're using prostitutes.
America will not accept
that complete insanity.
The world will accept if you waiver.
I think we all know we have skeletons.
I don't even wanna know what
the (beep) Steve's up to.
- Thanks Gary, I appreciate that.
- You're welcome, no worries.
I think that we, I'm excited
and I hope I live through seeing it.
And I may not.
It might be much longer,
but I do want to see,
I'm very, I wish people
lived the life that I live
which is, of course I judge people,
but boy do I unjudge them very quickly.
Humans are flawed, like in so many ways,
and we need to start accepting
our shortcomings a lot more
and I wonder if this data
thing, which sounds scary,
privacy's gonna go away,
it's very, it's Armageddon.
But I actually think
it's the starting point
to a better society.
- I like it.
- Yeah, interesting, right?
That's it?
- [India] That's everything.
- Alright Lewis, wanna
do any parting shots?
We're gonna link up on the book
on YouTube and Facebook for you.
- Yes, check out the book!
I'd appreciate it, this is my right hook.
Thanks for having me on.
- Anything else on your mind?
How much longer, how long
are you gonna do the podcast?
- It's been almost three
years, 245 episodes today.
And I don't see myself
slowing down anytime soon.
It just keeps getting bigger and bigger.
The impact--
- Who was today's guest?
- Today it was just myself.
It's great this week so it's all,
everyday I'm doing a lot more--
- Who was the last guest?
- The last guest, I'm
drawing a blank right now.
I can't remember.
- Recently?
Who have you had on recently then?
- I had--
- What happens?
Is the reason you don't
know because you can them
and then roll them out?
- Exactly, yes.
I had Phil Rosenthal actually
the last set, on Monday.
- Yes, Phil, good friend, good dude.
He's interesting right?
- He's hilarious, yes.
- Created Everybody Loves Raymond.
- He's amazing, yeah.
So he was great.
Here I'll finish with a quote.
- OK, yeah, do your thing.
Is it gonna be we find out
that everyone's a freak?
- No, no, no, this is
a quote that embodies
what you've taught me and what
I've learned my whole life.
The reason that I feel like I've been able
to get to where I'm at.
And I think where everyone
can get to where they're at
is a quote, I forget who said this,
but when I heard it
when I was a younger kid
it really meant a lot to me.
It made me feel like I had a chance.
And that's "Nobody cares how much you know
"until they know how much you care".
- Hmm, I like that.
My favorite quote is
"J-E-T-S, Jets, Jets, Jets".
(laughs)
Is that appropriate?
- I like it.
- Thank you brother.
- Thanks man.
- Good luck.
- [Lewis] I appreciate it.
- [Gary] You keep asking questions
we'll keep answering them.
(hip-hop music)